most people look at this and say look  there's more taxpayers cash now being  spent on a problem of the government's  making this has been going on a very  very long time and their home secretary  has said that the Asylum system is  broken she's right about that they broke  it so yes this is a step in the right  direction but there's so much more that  needs to be done we need the National  Crime agency working Upstream to tackle  the people smuggling in the first place  and we desperately need a much better  processing of applications here I think  most people watching this have been  pretty shocked to learn that of all the  people that have that arrived by small  boats in 2021 only four percent have  been processed by this government so a  small step in the right direction but a  much bigger challenge that the  government still isn't gripping